ghost in the shell' is directed by
Rupert Sanders and star Scarlett
Johansson as the major and this is the
American live-action adaptation of
Masamune Shiro's original manga and mam
Ruo she's nineteen ninety five film a
film that I'm a humongous fan of that
film is very inspirational to me it's
one of my favorite animations of all
time so I went into this film about 50%
ecstatic it's even happening because
I've loved anime for a long time I
adored the stand alone complex show I
thought it was really fantastic and I
have wanted Hollywood to adopt anime and
realize how inspirational it can be and
see the art in it and not just treat it
as this thing that is Japanese that's
not for the United States and realize
just how awesome it is and how many of
our films have been inspired by anime
and so I was 50% as I said ecstatic the
other 50% of me remembered a little film
called Dragonball Evolution and a little
film called Speed Racer two times in
which I have been horrifically violated
by American live-action adaptations of
anime in particular Dragonball Evolution
as you guys know I'm a humongous DBZ fan
and that is my least favorite movie of
all time
[Music]
Oh
so I was very conflicted I was like I
want this to be so good but oh my god
don't get excited because you know
things that have happened in the past
and depression sets in and loneliness
and death this adaptation of ghost in
the shell' follows the major a girl who
was in a terrible accident and her body
was reconstructed and now she is part of
section 9 a futuristic police force that
hunts down cyber criminals and in this
case they are hunting
Cousy a man who has launched a one-man
war against a robotics company that he
says has harmed him and many other
people in the past so how was this movie
good this movie was good this is one of
the most visually faithful adaptations I
have ever seen of anything spectacular
cinematography they have created
masamune she rose world to a tee this is
a gorgeous film that is so stunning to
look at I think CGI is a fantastic tool
but if it's overused it becomes
noticeable in this film there is quite a
bit of it and it melds with some
breathtaking production design virtually
seamlessly the world of this movie is so
well realized this is the ghost in the
shell' universe on screen big-budget
they nailed that aspect of the movie
down pat there's also quite a bit of
sequences that are direct recreations of
memory oh she's film now what concerned
me going in amongst a lot of things was
that they were just going to be hollow
recreations of these scenes that I loved
so much from the original film without
much substance underneath gratefully
that's not really the case this movie
does retain a lot of the substance that
memory oh she's original film has well
it's not as fully realized as that anime
film which is just fucking perfect in my
mind it is a really good try and they
got really close to nailing the
substance as well the original film
dealt a lot with the line between
humanity and AI to blur their the gray
area there and what really is the
deciding factor between the two and that
is recreated pretty well in this film
because major
as a character is very conflicted she
has memories of her past that sometimes
glitch into her visual that she's
looking at and she's seeing things and
suddenly she gets this flashback or an
image gets inserted into whatever she's
looking at and she is recalling a past
that she believes she has but the people
who created her are saying that's false
and so she wants to do research about
herself and really dive deep into
whatever she was before so in regards to
things they actually improved upon that
is something they actually got better
the character of the major in this film
is actually a lot more compelling than
she was in the original anime film there
really isn't much to improve in that
film but if I were to pinpoint one thing
I would say they did a pretty smart
thing and focusing on fleshing out the
major a little more because I would say
that's the one thing in the anime that
could have been better
towards the second and third act I won't
get into spoilers but she learns more
about her past she starts delving into
her history and you can actually feel a
lot more for her as a character and as a
protagonist because it's more of a rich
and conflicted background than moto
Kusanagi had in the original film and
they actually improved upon that the
original film also touched a lot on
gender identity
moto Co was very curious about herself
there's a scene where she sees a
mannequin of herself that looks exactly
like her in a store window that's just
being used for display purposes and she
grows even more curious about herself in
that sequence this film has some of that
there's a really great scene where she
talks to a human woman because she
simply wants to touch her face and
figure out what it is that makes her
human what's different about her eyelids
what's different about her lips it's a
really fantastic scene and that does
hint that this version of the major is
also very curious about this herself
because she clearly doesn't view herself
from a sexual perspective in this movie
either
just like in my mario she's original
film she will often take her clothes off
in front of people making the botto in
this film feel uncomfortable just like
in the anime there is a very good
recreation of some of these themes it's
not a home run I would say it's a solid
base hit
this film is dumbed down in some ways
when compared to the original film this
is more of a straightforward good guy
bad guy scenario where the original film
was a little blurred at first I don't
want to get into spoilers again but
towards the third act of this movie that
line between good and evil does get
blurred a little bit more and that was
something I really appreciated because
some people you think are good perhaps
they have other motivations and while it
could be viewed as your typical
American twist to a screenplay where
something kind of gets thrown at you at
the last second I think it's a little
more complex than that one of my biggest
praises with this movie and something
that I am so happy to report is that the
score might actually be better than the
original Clint Menzel who I think is a
genius has delivered a gorgeous fucking
eargasm excoriate to buy it you do get
the original chorus that amazing choral
arrangement that is in the opening of
the original film this time it's at the
end credits and while I was watching the
opening of this watching the major be
created I was like man I wish I could
have Kenji Kawai is amazing score right
now but then Clint Manziel started and I
was like oh my god this is fucking
awesome this music is amazing and I
really can't praise the music enough it
really sold this world and it just
sounded so good let's talk about the
Scarlett Johansson thing because it's
pretty much impossible to avoid there's
a lot of controversy of course because
this is a movie and movies get
controversy and so do TV shows
everything's controversial she's white
and Motor Co Kusanagi is technically a
Japanese woman in the comics as well as
the film despite the fact that she is
almost entirely cyborg her brain is
still you know a Japanese one and so
people were very upset about that look
there's nothing I can do about it I can
only judge the final finished product
and ScarJo is great in this movie she's
really good as his character and most
people in Japan like there's a really
great video on YouTube of someone
showing the picture of Scarlett to
Japanese people in Japan and universally
100% of them are like she looks great
I'm excited
see anymore you'll be radio chatter okay
uncle
Annie economical ominous can talk your
civilized oh yeah oh yeah no fun
yes hauntings and I think you know
because I eat almost talking about to me
it's really more so here in America that
we've got up in arms about all this
lately like iron fist I just talked
about it in my review of iron fist it's
a thing now it's like we have to make
everything perfectly ethnically caste
and nobody can play things and blow but
she's really good in the movie she is
there's nothing I can do about it
would it have been better with an Asian
woman it's the same screenplay it's the
same dialogue it's the same directing it
might have been more faithful but in the
end ScarJo is really good in this movie
she kicks ass in the action scenes and
she gives a lot of emotion to the role
about as much as you could give to a
role playing a mostly cyborg person
there is also an entire storyline which
I cannot spoil that is dedicated to what
she was before and I think some fans
might be confused by it some might think
it's cool
others might hate it I really actually
don't know what people will think of
that storyline for myself I thought it
added a very off-kilter emotion to this
film that I've never really seen in
another something very original that I
haven't seen done before in a film a
very interesting familial tie that I
thought was very charming actually and I
don't know people think of it but I am
very pleased to report that this is an
extremely faithful adaptation the things
they have changed actually in some ways
did improve it there is a little bit of
a dumbing down of the material I was
afraid it was just going to be a bunch
of matrix action scenes but it's
actually not there isn't really like a
big epic sequence like there's no like
half hour the end of the matrix sequence
where it's just balls out action there's
a lot of amazing action moments that are
gloriously beautiful but there is
actually more of a focus on the sci-fi
element and this odd futuristic Blade
Runner type feel for some people it's
going to feel derivative but they don't
realize that ghost in the shell' was so
inspirational to movies like Dark City
and The Matrix and if you were one of
the people like me back in the day who
watched it when it was first in its
heyday then you understand how much of
this
has impacted other films in the world
the original 1995 film and it has
recreated extremely well here the
villain koozie also took me off-guard
with the way they took his character I
didn't expect it and it surprised me is
it as good as the puppet master no it is
not as interesting on a psychological
level as the original film is and that's
this film's biggest flaw
I think but from a visual perspective
the action in the film performances I
really like Votto as well they recreated
him really well his love of basset
hounds which is also Mamoru Oshii his
big thing is basset hounds they really
got a lot right in this movie and I
think it is getting too much hate based
off of the race of the lead actress
beyond that I am very pleased this is no
Dragon Soul evolution it's no Speed
Racer this is the best American
live-action anime adaptation that we
have ever received and I really hope
that this bodes well for the future of
things like perhaps Akira or Cowboy
Bebop it's not perfect the themes and
the emotion of the psychological aspect
of the original film isn't as good as it
was in 95 but everything else is
extremely faithfully recreated in the
things they changed I liked I'm going to
give ghost in the shell and a - guys I
hope you check out this movie give it a
chance it is nowhere near as bad as some
people were concerned with don't judge a
book by it's cover go see it or in this
case a movie go see it and then decide
for yourself guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]